Guten Tag meine Damen und Herren! Herzlich
willkommen an der Landesverteidigungsakademie,
am Institut für höhere militärische Führung.
Mein Name ist Oberst Sandtner und ich bin
der Referatsleiter des Referats Führungslehre an
diesem Institut. Worüber wir uns in den nächsten
Minuten unterhalten wollen, ist der Krieg in
der Ukraine und zwar genau über Führung und
Führungsfähigkeit als den entscheidenden
Faktor in einem Umfeld, das von Dynamik,
Unvorhersehbarkeit und Komplexität geprägt
ist. Lassen Sie uns nun einige Beobachtungen
im Bereich Führung machen. Ich möchte mit der
russischen Seite beginnen und dort genauer mit dem
Verhalten der russischen Kommandanten.
Die russischen Kommandanten folgen offensichtlich
dem Prinzip des Führens von vorne. Selbst
höchste Dienstgrade bis in die Generalsränge
werden direkt an der Front angetroffen. Die
russischen Kommandanten befinden sich auch
dort, wo das Schwergewicht der Kräfte ist;
also wo die Entscheidung gesucht wird. An
und für sich ist das nicht ungewöhnlich.
Was allerdings schon ungewöhnlich ist:
Dass sehr ranghohe Kommandanten sehr unmittelbar
dort sind, wo das Gefechtsgeschehen stattfindet und
sich dadurch natürlich auch gefährden. Warum das so ist, darüber können wir nur mutmaßen. Es gibt
allerdings einige Indizien, die dafür sprechen.
Der Misserfolg der gesamten Operationsführung,
sodass auch ranghohe Kommandanten genötigt
werden, unmittelbar an der Front Einfluss zu
nehmen. Gepaart ist das Ganze mit einem möglichen
Vertrauensmangel quer über die gesamte russische
Führungshierarchie. Sodass Kommandanten wieder
vorne Einblick oder Einfluss nehmen müssen,
weil sie ihren Untergebenen nicht vertrauen. Ein
weiterer Aspekt könnte oder dürfte die schlechte
Moral der gesamten russischen Streitkräfte sein,
wiederum sind hier hochrangige Kommandanten dazu
angehalten, durch persönliches Erscheinen an
der Front diese schlechte Moral zu heben. Was
manifest scheint, sind die Probleme in der
Führungsunterstützung auf russischer Seite.
Das bedeutet das Herstellen einer gesicherten
Verbindung zwischen Kommandanten, Gefechtsständen
und anderen Führungseinrichtungen. Deswegen sind
die russischen Kommandanten auch sehr viel dazu
angehalten, ungeschützte Kommunikationsmittel
wie Mobiltelefone zu verwenden und können daher
auch leicht aufgeklärt werden. Lassen Sie
uns nun auf die ukrainische Seite blicken.
Hier ist das ausgezeichnete Lagebild als
wesentlicher Aspekt für die ukrainische
Führung anzusprechen. Offensichtlich wird sehr
viel Satelliten- und Luftaufklärung betrieben,
gar nicht nur mit ukrainischen, eigenen Mitteln,
sondern auch mit Unterstützung und Rückgriffen
auf NATO-Assets. Insbesondere scheint im
Bereich der Satelliten- und Luftaufklärung
auch die Unterstützung durch die USA manifest
zu sein. Außerdem sogenanntes SIGINT (signals
intelligence) - also die Möglichkeit, elektronische
und elektromagnetische Signale zu orten,
Standorte festzustellen, Inhalte abzuhören und
damit auch Kommandanten, russische Kommandanten,
am Gefechtsfeld orten zu können. Hinzu kommt die
Beeinträchtigungsfähigkeit, also die Möglichkeit
russische Führungsunterstützungsmittel zu
stören oder zu unterbrechen. Und last but
not least auch eine entsprechende Wirkfähigkeit,
um dieses Lagebild auch auszunutzen. Was bedeutet
das nun auf dem Gefechtsfeld? Wie Sie hier, an
dieser Grafik sehen können, sind inzwischen bis
zu einem Viertel der Top-Führungskräfte, das
sind Generalsränge, im Einsatzraum der Ukraine
ausgefallen. Also von etwa 20 eingesetzten
russischen Generälen sind zumindesten fünf
inzwischen gefallen. Beispielsweise der Kommandant
und der Chef des Stabes der 41. Armee. Das ist
eine Armee die im Norden, im Bereich Charkiv,
eingesetzt wird. Wodurch diese Armee komplett
führungslos wurde. Der Kommandant der 29. Armee,
die im Nordwesten der Ukraine eingesetzt ist,
sowie der Kommandant der 150. Schützendivision, der
am 15.3. in Mariupol direkt an der Front gefallen
ist. Und der Kommandant der 8. Armee, der
ebenfalls erst letzten Samstag, am 19. 3, im Süden
gefallen ist. Zusätzlich dazu sind mindestens
13 Oberste, das sind Kommandanten von taktischen
Bataillonskampfgruppen, Fernmeldeverbänden
oder anderen Einheiten, inzwischen gefallen. Was
heißt das nun aus Sicht der Führung? Das heißt
Folgendes: Dass auf russischer Seite ein ganz
wesentliches Führungsprinzip, nämlich die eigene
Führung zu schützen, offensichtlich nicht erfüllt
werden kann. Auf der ukrainischen Seite, ein
genauso wesentliches Führungsprinzip: Nämlich die
Führungsfähigkeit des Gegners beeinträchtigen, zu
minimieren, was offensichtlich sehr sehr erfolgreich
betrieben wird. Jetzt könnte man sich fragen,
ob es Zufall ist, dass so viele russische
Führungskräfte ausgeschaltet werden. Nein. Hiezu,
um Prioritätsziele festzulegen - Führungskräfte,
Gefechtsstände der Führungseinrichtungen
sind nun einmal Prioritätsziele - gibt es
ein international standardisiertes Verfahren, das
sogenannte Targetingverfahren, das ich nun ganz
kurz erläutern will. Das Targetingverfahren ist
ein Verfahren zur Festlegung und Bekämpfung von
Prioritätszielen und gliedert sich in vier Phasen.
Die grüne Phase: Entscheiden, wo Prioritätsziele
festgelegt werden. Zum Beispiel Kommandanten
oder Führungseinrichtung. Die gelbe Phase:
Aufklären "detect", wo genaue Lage- und Zieldaten
dieser Prioritätsziele festgestellt werden,
und diese Ziele auch getrackt - also
verfolgt werden. Geht über in die blaue Phase,
Wirken "deliver", wo eine entsprechende
Waffenwirkung auf diese Ziele ausgeübt wird,
um dann in der roten Phase der Wirkungsaufklärung
"assess", festzustellen, ob diese Wirkung auch
im Ziel gelegen ist. Falls sie nicht im Ziel
gelegen ist, geht es weiter mit der Phase
"Aufklärung" und erneutem Wirken. Wie nun dieser
Targetingzyklus anhand eines generischen Beispiels
aus der Ukraine stattfinden könnte, mag ich Ihnen
auf der nächsten Folie zeigen. Stellen Sie sich
folgendes Gefechtsbeispiel vor: Eine russische
motorisierte Schützenbrigade, hier die 2.
MotSchützenBrigade, rot eingezeichnet am rechten
Bildrand zu sehen, hat einen Geländeabschnitt in
der Ukraine eingenommen und sich dort zur zeitlich
begrenzten Verteidigung eingerichtet. Eine
ukrainische Gegenangriffskraft, hier als Division
eingezeichnet, innerhalb der ukrainischen Flagge,
hat den Auftrag, in dieses Dispositiv einzubrechen
und den eingebrochenen Feind zu zerschlagen. Nun
erfolgt die Phase Entscheiden "decide". Seitens
ukrainischer Seite wird beurteilt, welche Ziele
in diesem russischen Dispositiv Hochwertziele und
Prioritätsziele darstellen. Nämlich Ziele, deren
Lokalisierung und Bekämpfung im Wesentlichen den
Erfolg der eigenen Einsatzführung beeinflussen.
Hiezu wird festgestellt, dass der Gefechtsstand
der 2. motorisierten Schützenbrigade, auf
russischer Seite, so ein Prioritätsziel darstellt.
Wir sind jetzt in der grünen Phase "Entscheidung". Sie
sehen diesen Gefechtsstand blau markiert. In der
nächsten Phase "Aufklärung", gegebenenfalls unter
Rückgriff auf Satellitenaufklärungsmittel,möglicherweise
mit Unterstützung der USA,
werden nun die genauen Lage- und Zieldaten dieses
Gefechtsstandes festgestellt, um in der nächsten
Phase "Blau" (Wirken/"deliver"), möglicherweise
unter Einsatz einer Drohne, genau jenen
Gefechtsstand auszuschalten. Und dann anschließend
in der "Roten Phase", Wirkungsaufklärung "assess",
möglicherweise wieder mit Satellitenaufklärung
oder anderen bodengebundenen Aufklärungsmitteln,
den Erfolg festzustellen. Offensichtlich sind die
ukrainischen Kräfte in diesem Targetingzyklus,
insbesondere was das Ausschalten von
Führungskräften und Gefechtsständen betrifft,
sehr sehr erfolgreich, wie die vorherigen Folien,
mit den hohen Ausfällen von Kommandanten auf
russischer Seite, uns bereits gezeigt haben. Was
bedeutet das nun, was hat das für Auswirkungen auf
die angreifenden russischen Kräfte? Die russischen
Kräfte sind durch das Ausschalten wesentlicher
Elemente der Führung mitten ins Herz getroffen,
könnte man sagen. Es sind einerseits sehr viele
einsatzerfahrene Kommandanten verloren gegangen,
darüber hinaus wesentliche Führungseinrichtungen
zerschlagen worden. Was bedeutet dies nun
zusammengefasst? Zusammengefasst bedeutet
das eine deutliche Reduktion der Führungsleistung
auf russischer Seite. Einerseits führt der Verlust
vieler einsatzerfahrener Kommandanten dazu, dass
die Qualität der Führungsentscheidungen sinkt.
Andererseits führt die Zerstörung von
wesentlichen Führungseinrichtungen dazu,
dass auch die Geschwindigkeit der Aufbereitung von
Führungsgrundlagen und damit die Geschwindigkeit
von Führungsentscheidungen sinkt. Zusammengefasst
bleibt zu beobachten, ob all diese Geschehnisse
eine Anpassung der russischen Führungsprinzipien
mit sich bringen. Zum Beispiel, was die Lage von
Gefechtsständen betrifft, was den Einsatz von
Kommandanten direkt an der Front betrifft,
oder was insbesondere den Schutz von
Führungseinrichtungen und Kommandanten betrifft.
Wie zum Beispiel das Nichtverwenden ungeschützter
Mobiltelefonie und dagegen das Verwenden
geschützer Kommunikationsmittel. Herzlichen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und bis zum nächsten Mal!